I not want to be a one-and-done I not
want to be a flash in the pan I want to
be here for the long haul you got to
make a way when it doesn't seem to be
away you got to make away you had to
bust your ass roll up your sleeves and
attack attack attack attack every single
day he's an American film director
producer writer and actor his production
company 40 acres and a mule have
produced over 35 films since 1983 he's
won numerous awards including an Emmy
Award
he Spike Lee and here is my take on his
top ten rules for success rule number
six is our personal favorite I make sure
to stick around although to the end for
some special bonus clips and as always
if spike says something that's really
meaningful and relevant and inspiring to
you please leave in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well enjoy
I did not become a film it cuz I want to
be famous I not become filmmakers I want
to make a lot of money I became a filmic
as I found something I love
I'm professor NYU the grata film school
been here 15 years most director
artistic director to film school I tells
all my students the worst thing you do
is choose your major just based solely
on how much money thinking to make me
graduate if you want to be happy have a
happy life and not be miserable find
something that you love that's it
laziness is something I really can't
tolerate so because of laziness I think
that that speaks of a sense of
entitlement and that's just not a good
look in this industry where you think
that you would title to something that
you didn't you deserve something because
you're wherever you think you are it
doesn't work like that another thing I'd
like to add is that and I'm speaking
about my school a lot of people come on
NYU thinking that because you have this
degree from this pastiches prestigious
institution in weiu or USC or AFI
Columbia in a real world never really
give us you know if you don't have the
talent that degree doesn't mean a thing
when you come out of school you should
have if your directorship the film your
deep you should have a real editor
should have a real if your screen why
should have scripts so people on people
really want to see the work you've done
I came to the the mindset when I was in
film school marked that I'd not want to
be a one-and-done
I not want to be a flash in the pan I
wanted to be here for the long haul
it would incur a South the great affair
Carissa what I'm doing is doing press
was one of the last times Ron his
journals asked him you wanted a greatest
master filmmakers of all time
what else you still have to learn and
Kurosawa said I still have the universe
hmm to learn so I was in film school you
know and that blew my mind
the baddest ever right he's 85 eight
grated four he said he saucy saucy
University learn as far as storytelling
yeah that really hit me like you know
you really got a like the jazz term you
got you got to stay in the woodshed you
got a [ __ ] you know and constantly be on
it perfecting your crap and never get to
the point that you you trick yourself of
thinking that you know it all yeah it is
it's a life long journey you know what
distorts the tell stories how to craft
them just be good storytelling and and
you do that by having a body of work so
it's always been on the body of work
that the reason why I've told the story
that I've told that so I want to tell
that particular time it's part of being
a human being you know it's something
that that makes us who we are my faith
filmmakers a story tones and that's why
I try to do you allows me to express
myself and share it with the world
everybody comes into the theater and
sits down in a chair and the dark room
today are we gonna affect how they view
the film how they receive it you want to
have some feeling about what that feel
is you know that depends on the person's
who they are in the experience
make a market was there Marco she's
gonna have it
there was no market hip-hop for those
hot guys in the Bronx start again again
and rapidly Dietzen melted
billion-dollar industry so
you got to make away when it doesn't
seem to be away you got to make away one
moment one of my favorite words is
visionary because
people visionary people see something
well no no no no one else can see and we
can see something when else to see you
call crazy alright but you see it and
you head other people they have no cats
will eventually that's without that's
what makes a good in everything so I
hope that that you know students here
Dillard you know they paintball open
you're growing and you're learning you
know not stand still against daddy what
makes a good storyteller I don't know
that's a right a tricks oval of fortune
cookie but what would from a pattern
patterns you've seen or things that
you've applied like were you just like
one move two moves on the board that
just that are gonna assure a certain
kind of qualitative you know my mentor I
sort the story tell has to believe in a
story that that purse is telling cuz you
don't believe in it boys is not gonna
believe in it so you really have to
believe that this is a good story I
really want to make any generalizations
but a lot of people I've spoken to have
spoken some great great filmmakers a
novelist they do stuff like an I write
an alga the one I want to read it right
this is a film I would want to see right
and hopefully yeah you hope and pray
that oils will be in tune right I mean
one of the greatest people with that
that gift I think of Steven Spielberg
yeah just has this no my intuition yeah
he knows we could put out the post and
what people want right that's good a
anecdote it's like if you don't if
you're not believing in it people see
we're gonna be faking the funk and peed
book in the toe three years of film
school I do a film my thesis numbers
called Joe's bed-stuy barbershop and
there wins the student County award I
won a student kami award back in 1983
so I had an agent man I thought that
spear books bill Burson call me Lucas
Fox Universal and it had a little
apartment of burlap on for green before
identification so I had my now the
student Kathy Ward is not like this it's
a wooden box with a circle with this on
it so I know for sure because I have a
student County Ward I'm gonna take over
Hollywood but a funny thing happens when
you don't pay my bail you don't take con
Edison and you don't play Brooklyn Ewing
gas the phone is turned off the heat
gets turned off and lights get turned
off so I was in the dark just by having
my student kami Award and then I woke up
and so that's when I learned the tough
less that nothing happens overnight
there's no such thing as an overnight
success and that's the biggest thing we
do to our young people to tell them but
there's a thing the Apple as all in
Excel you have to bust your ass roll
your sleeves and attack attack attack
attack every single day and NASA like me
telling my film students NYU the last 15
years how do you choose what's
interesting to you I mean how do you
decide something I have to feel
passionate about I mean it people don't
know this but to make a good film has to
be one of the hardest things known to
humankind that make I mean there's so
many factors that go into making a good
film and like filmmakers who are
passionate about this you kill ourselves
to do this so you spend a year two years
in Malcolm X I took two years that's
that's time out of your life and you
have to have that passion for the
subject matter for the store whatever it
is
it makes you want to go ahead and press
a fear
I'll give the same advice to aspiring
filmmaker and writer right
both for those disciplines you need to
write and there's something I tell my
film students I've been teaching I've
been a professor NYU last 15 years the
grad of film school where I went and if
you did a survey the last 25 years and
looked at the first films of directors I
would say a large percentage of those
films those directors wrote that script
so I think that's a big clue when took
my films that if you want me director
you could write also you're a much
better chance of getting the first film
eight do the right thing that's what
many are saying the Spike Lee is they
call on the same director to end his new
Kickstarter campaign now if you don't
know Kickstarter is a website that he'll
take hey we're gonna go there why we
open like that because we're all about
controversy here we're going to let you
answer in a second but I get to tell
what people people want the Kickstarter
thing is it's a website how would you
open that helps artists fund their
projects using crowdsourcing here's how
it works you make your pitch in the
video you upload it you hope the idea
takes off that's mostly for
up-and-coming novices so what is an
oscar-nominated director like Spike Lee
doing on this set we thought we'd ask
him in person well I would like to
refute your opening Oh tell me I mean
you've got a lot of money you don't need
four students why would we show
Kickstarter I think it's interesting for
first of all you know how much my have
you never seen before never seen before
in your life
so if you assume what might be net what
my financial state is that's wrong
second of all I've been doing
kick-starting before there was kick
story you know I may not finish can I
finish please
only have six minutes so I would like to
get my voice in I'm into a Kickstarter
before the was Kickstarter that's how I
raised my my first one she's gonna have
it so why go to Kickstarter that if
you're really cutting white because
because cloud funding is the new wave
they get financing crowdfunding where
you go directly to your base
directly to the people who love she's
gonna have it schooldays do the right
thing
Malcolm X uh he got game summer same xx
our Inside Man Kings of Comedy
Kobe doing work that's a body of work
that's been a mass over three decades
and I'm going directly to the people
other people well no no no I want to
know what the different about that and
now so you've done it much different is
that the whole Hollywood game has
changed now Studios only want to make
Ted pull films that open on the same day
globally and make trillions of dollars
this which by the way aren't doing well
this year and that's the same thing WAIS
Kilburg and George Lucas themselves you
might say create the blockbuster from
non phenomena said that this path of
tentpoles
is going to collapse the whole Hollywood
industry and that's not me that's
Philbrick Lucas is saying that so so
therefore when I want to do my new film
coming out Thanksgiving weakens all boy
that studio film Josh Brolin and Sam
Jackson this is a film that is
independent film I'm an independent
filmmaker so I'm appealing to my so give
me your going deal into my base he'll
come on Kickstarter calm the plays as
little as five dollars to help me get a
new era hit mine you got your 30 get out
to get my new film eight three one and a
quarter million yes and your your third
of the way there when it make it much to
your chagrin
we'll make it people hey don't worry
about her so what
don't worry about his liking it don't
worry but handle like her out we're
gonna get it I have all for you making
this film I'm trying to understand why
you know I got you cannot be that only
might feel with I segment like that a
very excessive grain they now how pure
hatred I'm sorry Trish but let me tell
you something I contradict the concerns
of a couple out there it's like that is
my job this is not my concern
it's people turning to hide the concern
I would do right king release black
people run them up and riot so what does
that mean I would have to share a
concern of what some have said so okay
you got to be able to take the criticism
right oh I'm taking it I thought I don't
know I'm not going to stop here it may
just let you say this though without me
refuting it
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because fredericka fonta
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of spikes
rules had the biggest impact on you what
did he say that was really memorable and
meaningful to you leave it in the
comments I'm going to join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Stacy crew Stacy thank you
so much you're picking up a copy of my
book your one word it really really
really means a lot to me so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourselves and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
I've been very fortunate that to make it
averages out to film here 86 we made two
this year but I'm very happy about that
because I think that's the only true
where you're able to intelligently put I
mean evaluate an artist work so often
today somebody does one movie one album
one play one book and dinair genius and
it doesn't work like that you had to put
together you have to be consistent yet
to put together body of work and that's
how you evaluate artists I mean somebody
comes in to MBA and have a good year
they say this guy's our next Michael
Jordan you know that's bull you if you
could do what Michael Jordan's done but
ten nine years every year at the top of
this game then you're able to say to
compare somebody but they've only been
in the league one year how could you
make that comparison you just can't do
it
what advice would you give to artists of
color LGBT artists women artists artists
who are outside of the dominant culture
what would you tell us on how to nurture
and nourish ourselves so that we have
careers as long and as varied as
beautiful as yours is it a different
reality for somebody who's making the
film in the margins as opposed to what
she said the dominant culture yeah but
you can't let that stop you when I was
in film school there was only when I was
in weiu film school from 1979 1982 there
was only one african-american direct the
work and Hollywood period his name is uh
Michael Schultz excuse me and at the
time he was directing Richard Pryor's
films Richard Pryor was a biggest star
in Hollywood so if I'm in film school
and stays only one I mean if I'd have
thought about those odds
it would have hitted me so what do you
make of Cong Kaepernick not standing up
I support him I find it so interesting
how people want to pick and choose what
rice people have now anytime you talk
about anti gun violence
he went around screaming about they
don't want their second Amendment rights
to be infringed upon the same way John
Carlos and Tommie Smith raised their
black glove fist and 68 Olympics in
Mexico the same in Muhammad Ali refused
to fight for injustice award I was crazy
refused to buy the vs the Vietnam War
these are right Americans have you see
you see what he is doing what Colin
Kaepernick is doing is in that tradition
yes it's in a tradition of black
athletes standing up using a platform
saying I'm not happy with the way black
people people call it being treated it's
so interesting because often at the time
when an athlete does it
they are vilified oh that's the thing
later Oh
I mean Muhammad Ali biggest revision
story ever
Muhammad Ali one time was the most hated
person huh people need to Google right
do research Muhammad Ali was the most
hated person America he couldn't box it
yeah but how many people love is him
lighted the torch
where's arm is shaking hmm and land and
then in the early Olympics in Atlanta
yeah but not to defy it right
he said no Viacom ever called I'm not
gonna say the n-word run and he
sacrifice your your problems with my
prime use his name there was home
Cassius Clay came 90 calling the guy's
name so I think this is in the same
tradition what I find a lot like Darius
I find it very interesting
that three members a big blue the new
New York Football Giants one pleasant
unpleasant presently playing and two
retired or the ones that criticizing
them three other new that's my team
football three those brothers they
should I'm really I'm not they should
understand in what tradition the history
of why Colin did this now I bet you went
to all three of they were steady love
Mohammed Ali how you love my homily and
I loved him for the stance he took not
to be inducted into the Nam war if you
say you like John Thomas uh Tommy's
peduncle yeah yeah yeah it's the same
thing
Mohammed Ali said if I kept my mouth
shut just because I can make millions
than this ain't doing nothing so I just
loved the freedom and the flesh and
blood of my people more so than I do the
money and Jackie Robinson said I cannot
stand and sing the anthem
I cannot salute the flag I know that I'm
a black man in a white world though
Jackie Robinson 1972 in his
autobiography it is so interesting me
how and this is the tradition what colin
is doing now is not just come on a pop
out of nowhere there's tradition
tradition of ask america athletes
standing up and saying it's using a
platform to say something is wrong do
you think he's gonna pay a price for it
i mean there they all do
mime elite three years of his prime
Giancarlo's tommy smith oh of course
but these brothers do this knowing that
degree ramifications and they don't care
because this is a belief it's a and i'm
down to second they always bring up oh
you're making a lot of money so the
reason because you make money that means
that you can't have a moral foundation
and speak I mean like is here's the
thing black athletes we pay you money
play ball shut up don't say nothing
we're giving you money millions of
dollars just to go out there run up and
down the gridiron I mean there have been
rolling down the court
and just be quiet and play they haven't
a lot of athletes who don't want to risk
you know their spot there's endorsement
deals things like that I understand that
is all it's all individual choice but
when someone has the courage to step out
with knowing they can lose all that why
are you going to jump on the brother man
do you stand up during the national
anthem yes but it's a it's a personal
choice that is not a me Stefan me stand
up so the natural have to not affect me
do a Malcolm X or do the right thing
with all the all the other documentaries
so that's not do it to me you know I
stand up
and yet I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
yours I know for his right not to yes